when I first started working as a
consultant and communication coach over
20 years ago there's a sign on the wall
of a meeting room that said no leader no
agenda no time limit no meeting in this
video you learn five tips for how to run
an effective meeting it certainly
includes elements on that side but other
details as well including a bonus tip at
the end that will really elevate your
meetings and we're going to consider
some of these the prerequisite practices
of running an effective meeting that
means practicing some of these elements
consistently will not guarantee that all
your meetings will be productive but
these habits will prevent you from
having unproductive and ineffective
meetings and there are some more
advanced tips that will elevate your
meetings that we'll talk about along the
way as well this is going to start out
really basic but I can almost guarantee
that if you are currently experiencing
ineffective meetings then your team is
not doing one or more of these five
practices plus there's that bonus tip
end so use this as a checklist number
one the meeting must have a leader this
might seem obvious but I've been to
numerous meetings especially committee
meetings where I work over the years
where the group is meeting regularly but
there's no one clear leader who's
driving it sometimes the actual leader
can't be there but they want us to meet
without them anyway to see if we can get
done this can be very confusing for
everybody so your first step is to
identify the leader beforehand and if
you're watching this video I'm going to
assume that you are the leader and the
rest of the tips will help you become
more effective number two you must have
a written agenda I strongly believe that
there should be a written agenda that is
sent out a day or so before the actual
meeting so that everybody knows how to
prepare beforehand and then can fully
participate once they arrive at least
send a bulleted email list of topics
that you'll discuss so to me this is
like having a leader in the first place
it's an obvious prerequisite but in my
experience no written agenda is almost
the norm for many meetings I've attended
those and those meetings are seldom
productive in the end a few years ago I
had to send multiple requests about a
meeting I was invited to but I didn't
know why I was asked to attend in the
first place I never received an answer
about what the meeting was about ahead
of time let alone a written agenda not
surprisingly the meeting was a complete
waste of time there are lots of
variations of agendas no two are
identical and it really depends upon the
Norms of your organization but generally
speaking agendas fall into two overall
categories there are meeting agendas
that focus on sharing information and
other agendas that focus on decision
making or problem solving in a typical
information driven meeting the agenda
will list topics like announcements
status updates various topics of
discussion including categories like old
business and new business
these meetings just keep everybody
informed this is often the type of being
that people will say that could have
just been an email instead of a whole
meeting which could be the topic of a
whole other video entirely less
frequently the other type of agenda will
emphasize the key decisions that need to
be made or the problems that the group
is there to solve a few years ago I was
the chair of my academic Department I'm
a professor we had a few meetings in a
row that focused on solving problems and
making some decisions around
restructuring our undergraduate
curriculum problem solving meetings like
this typically follow the traditional
problem-solving steps and you would see
this on the written agenda first we
identified the problem then we analyzed
the problem in more depth then we
generated possible solutions identified
our best Solutions and finally took
steps to implement our decision this
decision-making process took a few
meetings to complete but I've run other
meetings where we progress through the
entire problem solving steps and just
one meeting and there's nothing magic
about either approach to an agenda just
make sure you create an agenda for the
sake of clarity and distribute it early
get it out to everybody in and so they
can prepare fully and then show up and
participate fully and that leads to our
next tip number three each person must
know what the leader expects of them to
contribute to each meeting I believe
strongly that the group leader should
let each individual person know
specifically how they should prepare to
participate in any upcoming meeting so
in addition to sending out the agenda I
always write a quick email or have a
quick conversation where I say to each
specific person you'll notice that I've
listed you on the agenda for an update
on Project Z in the meeting could you
let us know how things are going mention
any recent accomplishments on Project Z
and what your next steps are and provide
a rough timeline for when you think this
phase will be completed if there are
eight people on my team I'll send up to
eight separate emails letting each
person know how I'd like them to prepare
to contribute and it works great when I
prepare people like this they know why
they're there and the first place they
bring their a game because the
expectations are clear the more
experienced team members will need less
guidance over time but if there's a
brand new person on the team I also let
them know that while I'm not expecting
them necessarily to prepare anything big
I'd like them to make a contribution and
look for ways to add value even when we
are simply discussing an issue I'll say
to them to be sure you number one ask a
question during the meeting number two
offer your point of view and number
three build on what other people are
saying those are the three easiest ways
to get a new person up to speed and
contributing as soon as they join the
organization number four the leader must
encourage and facilitate maximum
participation during the meeting itself
nobody likes attending meetings that are
life lesson nobody's contributing so in
addition to the previous tips it's also
a good practice to send any additional
materials I'd like them to read ahead of
time and let them know how to prep up
for those specific discussions but the
key to encouraging maximum participation
is by preparing good discussion
questions ahead of time in a meeting
situation the best way I've seen this
done is first the leader provides some
sort of information a stimulus we'll
call it second the leader then asks a
clear prepared question to get a
response the stimulus might be a report
you send out earlier maybe some feedback
you heard recently the stimulus could be
anything and here's how it looks in the
moment you pull up the report or
feedback or whatever information you're
sharing and you keep it up so the group
can see it the entire time and then you
ask one clear question at a time you
might even write the questions on the
agenda you could put one question up at
a time on a slide depending upon the
Norms of your organization the
information in this example a report the
feedback plus a clear question will
create the ideal conditions for a good
discussion if you miss either of these
you will probably not generate as hell
helpful of a discussion as you could
have groups have the best discussions
when the leader provides the stimulus
and then asks them to respond number
five and then I'll give you the bonus
tip you must have a clear time limit for
lots of reasons a time limit will make
the group work more efficiently rather
than waste time the number one thing
that makes people work more efficiently
in a group is when people notice the
time so at some point in every meeting
I've been in somebody will say oh we
only have 20 minutes left let's get
moving so use that sensibility to your
advantage by signaling the time limits
once in a while and at a minimum a time
limit will at least bring the
ineffective meetings to a close and end
everybody's misery a time limit also
puts more pressure on the leader to be
at his or her best a time limit makes
the leader manage the time more
effectively in the moment and move the
conversation forward when it's dragging
a time limit will encourage the leader
to reign in and refocus members who tend
to ramble and go on tangents a time
limit will encourage the leader to make
sure the overall pacing of the meeting
flows well so the proper amount of time
is devoted to the most important topics
of discussion one of the positive pieces
of feedback I received on my annual
review when I was a chair that I was
secretly the most proud of was that the
faculty believed that we never had a
wasted moment in meetings every minute
was time well spent and now for the
bonus tip the tip is to leave more space
for your team members to talk to each
other instead of a mindset of quote
running the meeting see yourself as
quote facilitating a meeting here's what
I mean the most common pattern I've seen
in meetings is where a team member will
say something or ask a question and the
leader then is the first person to
respond this creates a pattern where the
leader is really having a bunch of
one-on-one conversations even though
you're in a group it looks like a
straight line of communication going
back and forth between the leader and
each person meetings like this rarely
feel Dynamic and energetic and at short
circuits what could have been a good
discussion instead those kinds of
meetings lack creativity they lack
collaboration in short this doesn't take
advantage of the power of the group
which is one of the key reasons to have
a meeting in the first place instead of
a back and forth line visualize the
communication pattern like a star like
the kind of star you draw where the
communication bounces from one person to
the next until it goes full circle and
you as the leader can create this
pattern to start it when you ask a
question or when somebody says something
resist the temptation to jump in leave
more time and space for the other team
members to respond so you'd still listen
carefully use good non-verbals like eye
contact and nodding maybe you'd make a
small verbal utterance like ah or um
you'd still affirm them non-verbally in
other words but instead of saying
something or articulating your idea look
around the room to invite responses from
others you could even ask them what do
you all think
the goal of this is to get the team
members talking to each other in ways
that lead to a dynamic and collaborative
discussion and keep asking questions to
keep that conversational ball rolling
the conversation then becomes one that
you facilitate rather than run or manage
if you get the conversational Dynamics
right your meeting will be 10 times more
satisfying for everybody
here's the expanded checklist based upon
the sign that I saw on the wall and that
consulting company I work for plus the
other tips we added today again many of
these are prerequisites that means this
doesn't ensure you'll have lots of
amazing meetings but it will virtually
guarantee your pointless meetings and
many of the other tips about generating
more discussion will help level up any
team's conversation be sure to take a
look at the resources in the description
below including a free pdf download of
the top five essential communication
skills that every professional should
have until next time thanks God bless
and I will see you soon